les vendanges sont bien avancés dans le
vignoble de bourgueil la moitié de la
récolte est maintenant passé dans les
pressoirs et si les viticulteurs est
bien sûr cliquez sur terre cette année
sera pour eux l'occasion de rêver
c'est l'année qu'on rêve un petit peu
une année de qualité et une année de
quantité généreuse jouer c'est une c'est
un très bon raisin ça l'état sanitaire
est à leur est arrivé
alertant et sucré donc au coût de sucre
bonne qualité une année extraordinaire
des premiers jus de raisin titre jusqu'à
12 degrés ce qui est remarquable en
appellation de passionnés d'art et
recueillie à plus de 80% à l'aide de
machines
la machine est lancée par exxon sans
cesse voici la dernière née avec
passager s'il vous plaît embarquement
immédiat
nous ramassons avec une machine mais
nous trions sur la machine manuellement
j'ai quatre personnes sur la machine qui
trie au fur et à mesure que la vendange
arrive nous avons une table de tri
charme agit davantage c'est que vous
avez un raisin qui arrive dans la cub
qui est parfait il n'y a pas de
d'aborder 3 2 pour de feuilles dans le
pretium au petit morceau de bois
donc tout est parfait en fin de semaine
prochaine toute la récolte sera rentré
commencera lors la lente et subtile
alchimie de la vinification